I went out drinking last night
real drinkin yeah all right you can
applaud drinkin real man drinking you
know the kind of drinking you do when
you get that new job or when you lose
that new job and when I want to drink
like that there's only one place that I
like to go and that's a dive bar dive
box yes thank you thank you for greeting
that with applause instead of being like
Pete you do not look like a dive bar
kind of guy you have stuffed animals on
your couch and I do once the Joker got
on Etsy yeah there's Tigger so real it's
real but I love a good dive bar I really
do they're the best bar is because they
have zero flash no flash no frills whole
place smells because they haven't mopped
in years because they can't because it's
carpeted so dark and a good dive bar you
can't see your hand in front of your
face because the windows are so filthy
no light gets through or they just don't
exist
just like yeah health inspectors said we
could either have one real window or two
paintings of fake windows we went with
the paintings the drinks are so cheap
and you could legitimately complain that
they give you way too much
that's a dive bar when you're like this
is a single as far as you can tell the
place doesn't even have a kitchen yet
the guy next to you is housing a pretty
decent plate of wings
where'd that come from tie bars there
bars stripped a hundred percent to their
core
there's no mega touch machine too bright
there's no band playing too loud there's
no flatscreen too flat there's no
activity the only activity having a dive
bar is getting to know the guy next to
you because he's doing the same thing
you are dive bars are great for that
reason because they're like low-rent
summer camps you know I mean right
that's the kind of summer camp I went to
and that's why I like dive bars no
tennis court no swimming pool no skeet
shooting all you have is each other and
poison oak that's like a dive bar but
that other camp the one across the lake
with the preppy kids and the
air-conditioned bunks and the golf
lessons that's some Dave & Buster's
right there Dave and Buster's oh they're
bleeping and bong and video games I'm
trying to drink I have enough to worry
about when I'm drinking potential
fistfights falling down stairs my pants
falling down my pants falling down while
I'm falling down some stairs
I don't need the added concern of
someone losing control of a ski ball
just like well yeah no you Dave and you
buster
and it's expensive when I want to get
completely hammered for $8.50 I'm headed
to the dive bar with their crazy drink
specials just like oh man
you get free two shots and the calzone
with every pair you buy looks like I
don't need to find a job tomorrow after
all I was needing a calzone but that's
gonna be a gift of something living on
the edge that's what I say a night of
boozing is all about don't get me wrong
huh sometimes I want to sit in a
gastropub and sip a single malt with a
ice cube that's not actually an ice cube
but a chilled stone I'll do that but
sometimes I want to pound tequila shots
let's scorch my throat with no wine
because I don't believe in them out of
shot glasses that still have lipstick
three different colors from last night's
bachelorette party I want a bar that
makes me feel tough the kind of bar
where if you dare to order a Shirley
Temple the boy trous brings you a sprite
with blood in it
just to teach you a lesson just like get
out of here with your pleasurably
flavoured 1930s child star soda pop
don't forget your blood sprites dive
bars don't have a big buck hunter
machine they forced you to put a quarter
into the game of life think of what
could happen in a die bar is it anything
it's anything you might meet a girl who
drives a big rig and dance with her to
the days of thunder soundtrack on the
jukebox cuz that's the only choice or
you might just end up becoming best
friends with a 98 year old man because
he is the only choice it's like Indiana
Jones was based on you huh I'd google
that but this place is sketchy and I
don't want to advertise that I have a
phone can you believe this is a signal
tie bars have good company good
conversation and booze so strong you're
not entirely sure it isn't Listerine and
you not Kuhlman's regular and you know
you're gonna see some amazing in a
dive bar just like that lady punched
that guy then they dry humped on the
pool table
then she served me these wings they're
totally tasted I didn't even know they
had a kitchen and the dive bar is always
there for you
recently got dumped go and get some
advice from sunny the bartender and you
know his name is sunny he knew that
going in the place is called Sunny's
that's why he's allowed to give you all
the free drinks and free advice you're
never gonna go into a Chili's with a
bartender like names chili run the place
we got a great show tonight
from HBO's Silicon Valley Zak widgets
here in live stick around